una mañana del 2012 al año haber
terminado el secundario
me levanté con la curiosidad de poder
averiguar la posibilidad de escribirme
en una universidad privada capital
buscaba acomodar mis horarios para poder
retomar los estudios y trabajar a la vez
y aunque venía de estudiar únicamente en
escuelas públicas
esta mañana curioso
motivados que una universidad privada y
pedía hablar con alguien que me brinde
información sobre la cuota mensual tema
del ingreso y demás
después de haber recorrido las
instalaciones de ese lugar que por
cierto me gustaron bastante
cuando llegó el momento de hablar sobre
el tema de los costos de ingresos la
cuota mensual y matrícula
para mí el importe era muy imposible de
pagar
y se ve que fue tan claro
es tan clara la expresión en mi rostro
que no hizo falta ni una sola palabra
para que la otra persona seguirá cuenta
eso de que yo no voy a pagar ese importe
fue en este momento que la persona que
me recibió me dijo que no me preocupara
que no me haga problemas y no lo podía
pagar que ese lugar no era para mí y que
vuelve al barrio que vuelve a la villa
que ese si era mi lugar
ese día me sentí recluido y discriminaba
a la vez
hasta pensé que
por ahí tenía razón lo que debería ser
así
pero no
y un montón de chicos chicas jóvenes
adultos viven esta situación de
discriminación y exclusión
todo el tiempo y sume moleres o la
inequidad y las injusticias que nos
rodean todo el tiempo
tenemos en nuestro país casi 41 por
ciento de pobreza
soy luis vivo acá en la villa 31 desde
los 2 años de edad con mi familia mis
padres emigraron de bolivia en búsqueda
de un futuro mejor
estas trabajaban mucho todo el día
prácticamente y yo me quedaba en la
guardería acá cerca del barrio o en la
casa de algún vecino que me cuidaba y me
daba para comer
el chico siempre fue una persona
bastante introvertida muy cerrada no
hablaba con mucha gente casi con nadie
y va la escuela del barrio quizá hasta
cuarto grado o giacometti de cambiar la
escuela porque los profesores pensaban
que la tarea de los dibujos buenas
hacían mis padres
de chico siempre me fue bien en la
escuela y aparte de dibujaba bien lo
admito
pero bueno cuando me cambié a escuela la
verdad que me sentía raro me sentía
diferente a los más chicos
ellos no eran tímidos donde no tenían
vergüenza hablaban con todo el mundo
eran como yo con 10 años me tocaba
viajar todos los días a una escuela
afuera del barrio
y como les digo me sentía diferente era
muy vergonzoso esa timidez y esa
vergüenza que tenía fomentando cuando me
empezaron a poner apodos en la escuela
como negro mísero cabecita o bowling de
bolivianos si no lo hemos escuchado no
hasta los profesores y profesoras a
veces me llamaba por algún apodo que me
ponían los chicos
mi problema no era aprobar las materias
mi problema era que me excluyan como
enseñarles por mi apariencia o por ser
de la villa
cuando llovía acá el barrio antes se
sentaba de barro todos lados y por eso
llegaba a la escuela todo todo embarrado
las zapatillas
pero solamente se burlaban de mí y a
veces terminaba llorando en el baño de
la escuela solo
odiaba que las cosas fuesen así
a pesar de todo terminé la primaria con
buenas calificaciones y la directora de
la escuela me consiguió una beca para ir
a una escuela secundaria privada
pero no la acepte decidí no aceptarla
porque cuando fui con mi mamá que está
acá presente a ver el lugar
vi que en la escuela privada todos te
llevaban uniforme todos tenían todo y
sinceramente iba a ser el único delito
de la villa y no la quería seguir
pasando mal
ya bastante tuve la primaria
tenía 13 años jamás todavía era chico
vamos a confeccionar la ropa me acordé
y yo le ayudaba a venderla en la salada
había que ayudar y a mí me gustaba
trabajar con mamá
terminó la escuela secundaria pública el
tiempo pasó llegué a quinto año con 18
años
y en paralelo a la escuela a la escuela
al quinto año me norte a una fundación
que capacitan a chicos de bajos recursos
para que puedan conseguir su primer
empleo blanco ahí aprendí muchísimo
sobre la búsqueda laboral arman un cb y
el trato con nuestros padres cosas muy
importantes a la hora de hacer un
trabajo
terminé el secundario y la formación con
buenos resultados
a los dos meses llegó el momento
esperado
primer mes del trabajo en blanco
era una empresa multinacional como
cajero
ahí aprendí montón cinco años aprender a
estudiar y trabajo en cinco años se
aprende muchísimo
después de en paralelo a eso
decidí trabajar porque en ese momento
las cosas en casa amiga muy bien papá
era el único que trabajaba y el único
que aportaba plata
y entonces tiene el deber de priorizar
el trabajo antes que estudiar
estuve cinco años en esa empresa después
para ser una empresa un call center
donde trabajé tres años y hacerlo con
center y hablas con muchas personas y
eso también me ayudó mucho a
sociabilizar y a poder hablar con los
demás y abrirme
tuve tres años en esa empresa
pero si algún momento en el que
sentí que era momento de cambiar de
rumbo
la monotonía y
me agobiaba y no dejaba de pensar
cómo hacer para sacar a mi familia del
barrio e irme yo también yo me quería ir
la hagan
claro no lo habíamos pasado también a
gas del barrio en la villa con mi
familia
era
qué hiciste acá arriba
fue así que a los 25 años conocí el
mundo conocí el mundo emprendedor
me empecé a notar en concursos que
lanzaba el gobierno de la ciudad de
emprendedorismo con un solo objetivo el
querer medir del barrio mi idea era
presentar un proyecto canario de capital
semilla que era plata y así pueden salir
del barrio
los proyectos no eran malos eran
bastante buenos incluso varias veces
llegaba a la final
pero no ganaba todos los proyectos serán
la esencia fuera del barrio nunca nada
adentro y siempre busque me la rebusco
buena afuera
sigue nunca gane los concursos y me iba
bien hasta expuse en el festival
masticar un proyecto
me lleva a algo que era importante para
mí sabía que me iba a servir a futuro
que eran los contactos y las personas
que hacían esos concursos
en el año 2017 conocí a mediados de ese
año conocí a las personas que
organizaban esos tipos de concursos
el ministro de andy freire en su momento
y el director de emprender en la ciudad
santiago zen a quienes me propusieron
participar en el pacto emprendedor que
es un programa era un programa que
juntaban un emprendedor se ha realizado
con uno que recién estaba empezando el
que recién estaba empezando era yo
y la verdad que ese programa me ayudó un
montón para poder darme cuenta que
estaba poniendo el ojo en todo lo
negativo que me haya pasado del barrio y
por eso mi perspectiva únicamente era ir
me estaba mirando todo lo malo sin darme
cuenta todo lo lindo que tiene el barrio
todo lo que me había brindado su gente
es vigente y todo lo que hoy en día soy
después de tanto pensar y analizar en
hacer un proyecto se ve adelante el
primer festival que hicimos acá en el
barrio del día del niño en agosto de
la ley que salió muy bueno me ayudaron
varios amigos de trabajo en el que
estaba center
hicimos un festival bastante lindo
conseguimos mayorcitos juguetes
meriendas música y hasta una obra de
teatro para los chicos
ese día me sentí feliz me sentí muy
realizado y ya no me quería ir del
barrio al contrario
después de haber realizado mi problema
mi primer proyecto social y haber
debutado como emprendedor social
les mostré lo que habíamos hecho a los
encargados de los concursos de santis
cera y andy de habla que felicitaron y
le gustó mucho lo que había avanzado y
como dice este cambio de paradigma de mi
cabeza y me propusieron poder participar
en un congreso mundial de juventud en
singapur
de
verdad me siento para motivarme para que
me anime y que siga con los proyectos me
acuerdo que cuando llegó el día yo no
tenía ni pasaporte ni siquiera había
viajado en avión nunca y pensé que no
iba a pasar todavía
y fue por eso que me tuve que hacer los
trámites a las chapas rápido todo
trámite rápido para poder viajar todo
bien no lo creía
en septiembre de 2017 participemos con
con este mundial de juventud sobre salud
y empleo joven nada más y nada menos que
a singapur
estuve representando al país allí y hoy
ambiente al barrio 31 ya mi gente
conocí montón sobre su cultura y aparte
conocí mucha gente de otras partes del
mundo que estaban haciendo cosas muy
grosos por su comunidad
volví a ese viaje rancho fado la hora
que me motivó mucho público muchas ganas
de seguir haciendo cosas acá en el
barrio y generar un impacto positivo
para nuestra comunidad
y así lo hicimos
después de haber armado un grupo de
amigos acá en el barrio haber sido
adelante mi proyecto el primer proyecto
en el barrio
tenía ganas de retomar los estudios
habían pasado varios años
al año siguiente es el gran viaje el
por medio de una conocida
aplique para una beca en la universidad
privada que queda en san fernando
y después de varios años fue complicado
retiene el examen de ingreso pero con
esfuerzo lo pude aprobar y con una buena
calificación y pedir la beca al 100%
tenía miedo tenía miedo que me pase lo
mismo que me ha pasado con el chico que
me excluya lo que más rechaces dos
señales por dónde venía
toda la verdad que me encontré con una
comunidad universitaria para villosa
que nos acompañó desde el día 1 y me
sigue acompañando hasta el día de hoy
hoy con 29 años estoy cursando la
carrera de ciencias políticas y
gobiernos
estoy en tercer año de la carrera
soy presidente y fundador de social de
una asociación civil acá en el barrio
que está conformada por amigos y vecinos
y vecinas de acá del barrio 100 por
ciento del barrio
con un único objetivo que es generar un
impacto positivo en nuestra comunidad
y también genera la oportunidad para
mejorar la calidad de vida de muchos
nuestros vecinos
así que mi mensaje por último para todos
las personas de acá del barrio de toda
la villa de la ciudad y el país es que
no importa de dónde vengas no importa
lo que te digan de vos como te digan lo
que digan sobre su situación económica
lo que importa es cuan dispuesto estás
a trabajar para crear y llegar a
alcanzar tu proyecto de vida
vengas de donde vengas
pero para eso también necesitamos un
estado realmente presente que acompañe a
esas personas que quieren salir adelante
pero que sea real que no solamente sea
por la foto y en época de campaña y
también necesitamos instituciones
educativas sin prejuicios que le brinden
las oportunidades a la gente que menos
las tienen
porque muchas veces la gente de la villa
saben que solamente necesitamos eso una
oportunidad para poder aprovecharla
muchas gracias
quería decir lo último muchas gracias
por acercarse al barrio la verdad que
para mí es un honor estar acá presente
me encanta todo lo que veo todo todo y
decirles que vengan al barrio más
seguido que el barrio hoy día está
cambiado y hagan su montón y se avanzó
lo que avanzó es gracias y puramente y
exclusivamente a la gente del barrio 31
de nadie más muchas gracias
[Aplausos]